live il est 20h54 Emmanuel Macron que
vous voyez encore sur ce player est en
train de parler là les images que vous
voyez c'est les les images du début de
l'interview qui aura duré au moins 2h
bienvenue donc sur le site du Figaro
vous nous dites ce que vous avez pensé
de l'intervention du président de la
République si vous l'avez vu ou si vous
l'avez avz suivi en direct sur le site
du Figaro il y a quelqu'un qui l'a vu
c'est vous Guillaume roquet bonsoir
bonsoir vcent merci beaucoup d'être là
on va pas vous retenir trop longtemps
parce que vous êtes en direct également
sur un autre plateau ce soir au
lendemain d'un boucllage pour un nouveau
très beau numéro du Figaro Magazine qui
sera consacré d'ailleurs au chrétiens de
Terre Sainte c'est bien ça j'ai pas vu
la couverture mais en tous les cas mon
délit d'initié m'a permis de savoir que
c'était sur ça que ça Noël à Bethléem à
Bethléem alors c'est pas Noël à Bethléem
ce soir dont on va parler mais on va
parler de cette interview de euh
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est la question
qu'on vous pose sur le le le site du
Figaro avez-vous été convaincu par la
prestation du président de la République
parce qu'il a dit on va y revenir et
vous pouvez également nous répondre sur
Youtube et sur le le la page Youtube du
Figaro euh Guillaume bien évidemment euh
vous allez faire comme les internautes
vous allez commenter vous allez réagir
et c'est donc à vous à tous seigneurs
tout honneur après plus de près de 2
heures d'interview un commentaire une
première analyse je pense que le
Président de la République lui-même
n'est pas convaincu par cette loi et
donc c'est une réponse à votre question
d'ailleurs au tout début de son
intervention c'est votre première c'est
votre premier sentiment après l'avoir
entendu vous l'AVE pas trouvé éloquent
vous pas trouvé je l'ai trouvé je l'ai
trouvé Pug je l'ai trouvé pugnas
habile dialecticien chevronnis et tout
ce qu'on connaît comme qualité à
Emmanuel Macron mais il a commencé par
dire que il y avait des choses qui ne
lui plaisaient pas dans cette loi à ma
connaissance c'est la première fois
qu'il a ce genre de de d'aveu et on
avait vraiment le sentiment que cette
loi dans une large mesure il l'a subi
c'est-à-dire que c'était presque un aveu
d'impuissance qu'on avait ce soir il
disait bah écoutez j'ai pas de majorité
il a bien fallu que je compose avec des
parlementaires d'autres formations
politiques et s'il a euh nié que c'était
un succès pour le rassemblement national
il a quand même expliqué que c'était pas
la loi du départ et que d'ailleurs il
allait déférer un certain nombre
d'articles devant le Conseil
constitutionnel ce qui est bien la
preuve que ça ne le satisfait pas c'est
quand même assez étonnant 25 articles
hein sur les 88 que compte la loi qui
serait en tous les cas euh litigieux ou
ou étudiable par le Conseil
constitutionnel voilà et ça montre le
degré de de
d'irresponsabilité ou de ou de ou de
manœuvre du gouvernement et d'Emmanuel
Macron sur ce sur cette loi puisqueen
fait c'est un projet de loi
gouvernemental qui a donc été à la
demande du gouvernement adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale alors que ce même
gouvernement et le président de la
République savait pertinemment qu'il
avait toute une partie qui n'était pas
constitutionnelle cette séquence est
vraiment me semble-t-il un exercice de
gribouille du début à la fin ce que vous
êtes en train de dire Guillaume c'est
que apparemment selon vous euh le
gouvernement aurait laissé en conscience
en connaissance de cause une loi avec un
certain nombre d'articles litigieux pour
pouvoir les faire retoquer je pense
qu'il avait une nouvelle fois la la
volonté de de courir plusieurs lèvres à
la plusieurs lièvres à la fois le la le
premier objectif c'était de dire au au
français regardez l'immigration ça vous
préoccupe et bien nous répondons à vos
préoccupations par une loi et en même
temps il fallait essayer de de montrer
que c'est ce qu'il a dit ce soir
d'ailleurs he oui absolument faant un
petit peu la leçon au journalistes de au
journalistes de France 5 c'est vrai
parce que on n'est pas forcément dans ce
petit milieu médiatique vous le savez
aussi conscient que les Français de la
réalité de la PR un pe peu de cette
situation je sais pas je vais vous dire
euh euh ça fait presque 2 heures qu'on
écoute le président de la République et
il a surtout joué d'une espèce de de
de si je devais résumer mon mon
sentiment je dirais que il a fait comme
d'habitude le le l'exercice du premier
de la classe c'est-à-dire que sur tous
les sujets il avait une réponse il n'a
commis aucune erreur il est face à une
crise gouvernementale inédite et euh
plutôt que de concentrer son
intervention sur cette loi immigration
qui à juste titre provoque un trouble
dans sa majorité il en parle et après il
il il embrille sur le handbal féminin la
coupe de cheveux de Miss France l'avenir
d' Mbappé le prix du nesquck je vous
jure j'invent rien j'étais devant ma ma
caméra de télévision là aussi j'ai
écouté comme s'il fallait noyer cet
événement comme s'il fallait le
banaliser en en en en en faisant une
séquence parmi d'autres de cette de
cette actualité du mois de décembre
alors il y a un certain nombre de
réaction déjà sur la page Youtube du
Figaro et on sait salut les internautes
qui sont en train de nous rejoindre de
plus en plus nombreux merci soyez les
bienvenus c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
est en direct sur le la page Youtube du
Figaro et on est content de vous
retrouver on sait que vous êtes tous des
abonnés à cette page Youtube samarcand
nous dit ils sont entre entre amis il y
avait dans est-ce qu'il y avait pas
c'est un commentaire que je voulais vous
vous demander Guillaume avant de revenir
sur le fond de l'intervention du
président de la République quelque chose
d'un peu frappant dans cette dans cet
exercice du du président de la
République qui convoque une émission du
service public pour pouvoir parler
pendant 2 heur pourquoi croyez-vous
qu'il a choisi cette émission pour
parler c'est parce qu'il sait très bien
et c'est conseiller en communication
aussi que il y a dans cet avou une
atmosphère bienveillante c'est une sorte
de discussion c'est une émission sont
allé un petit peu quand même le chercher
oui un petit peu et Patrick en je trouve
a fait son travail mais on est autour
d'une table et on discute c'est une
émission purement horizontale
c'està-dire que c'est il y a pas de de
de de de de séquence plus marquante
qu'une autre encore une fois c'est une
espèce de conversation et je pense
vraiment que l'objectif du président de
la République c'était de de banaliser
cette crise de la majorité et en disant
bah finalement ça mérite qu'on en N
passe quelques minutes autour d'une
table avec des gens sympathiques mais ça
ne nécessite pas une intervention
solonnelle alors c'est peut-être ça qui
à quelque chose en tout cas d'assez
frappant dans dans ce que vous dites
Guillaume c'est
que finalement on aurait on aura passé
j'ai même hésité pour tout vous dire à
vous
appeler à vous appeler à à ce moment-là
euh à à à faire le le débrief de la
crise actuelle au bout de 30 35 minutes
euh tout ça tout compris avec la comment
dirais-je l'introduction le générique on
a passé finalement pas tellement de
temps sur la crise actuelle h oui parce
que je pense que Emmanuel Macron c'est
qu'il n'a pas de solution à cette crise
il n'est il ne peut pas se se renier il
ne peut pas
complètement se désolidariser de cette
loi puisque il l'a voulu il sait qu'elle
a provoqué une crise dans sa majorité et
maintenant son seul objectif c'est de
passer à autre chose de toute façon les
les les moyens qu'il a à sa disposition
sont très limités il ne peut pas
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale parce
que il serait à ce moment-là dans une
situation probablement encore plus
difficile pour lui il va sans doute
changer de Premier ministre mais il peut
pas le faire immédiatement parce que ça
serait un desaveux pour Elizabeth borne
donc qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire il peut
là je dois dire assez crânement quand
même expliquer à juste titre que cette
loi est tout sauf le retour des heures
les plus sombres de notre histoire que
dans un un un une rhtorique bien connue
la gauche essaie de de de de Don dans à
gauche essayie de nous persuader est-ce
qu'il a pas répliqué quand même à cette
gauche ce soir si il il lu a il a
répliqué en disant que il existe euh en
France un certain nombre de de mesures
sociales particulièrement favorables et
qui pouvait créer un une sorte d'appel
d'air il a aussi dit et à mon avis à
juste titre que il est extrêmement
difficile dans notre pays d'expulser des
clandestin et donc il a voulu dire qu'il
fallait prendre ce sujet à bras le corp
ce en quoi il a raison le problème me
c'est qu'à mon avis les réponses qui
sont données sont symboliquement fortes
et c'est en ça que le rassemblement
national peut parler d'une victoire
idéologique mais que concrètement je
pense que tout ça n'aura pas beaucoup
d'effet alors c'est une question très
intéressante que vous soulevez avec
cette cette en mentionnant le le
rassemblement
national lors de cette interview encore
et toute l'après-midi toute la soirée
d'hier on pouvait le suivre en direct
sur le site du Figaro tout le monde a
mon montré combien enfin tous les cas
tous ceux qui ont pris la parole à la
tribune hors républicain hors
rassemblement national ont montré euh en
tous les cas par parmi les partisans de
la loi donc Gérald armanin les membres
de la majorité que cette loi n'était pas
rassemblement national Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs déclare c'est une défaite
pour le rassemblement national et il
soulingne raison un certain nombre de de
de mesures qui sont pris notamment sur
la la possibilité de régulariser des
sans papiers de possibilité pour pour
les euh notamment pour les préfets le
fait qu'il a encore euh que l'aide
médicale d'État ne soit pas supprimée et
cetera euh un certain nombre de mesures
qui montrent que elles ne sont pas euh
des mesures qui étaient soutenu
jusque-là par par le rassemblement
national euh est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
en tout cas c'est ce que la question que
pose Éric Zemour dans une tribune euh
publiée par Le Figaro ces dernières
heures est-ce qu'on peut passer parler
vraiment d'une victoire idéologique pour
le rassemblement national alors je le
pense c'est une victoire symbolique pour
deux raisons la la première c'est
que il n'y a plus de tabou et quand par
exemple le temps de de carence avant de
pouvoir toucher quand on est un immigré
en situation régulière les allocations
familiales quand ce temps de de de
carence passe de 6 mois à 2 ans et demi
c'est effectivement un pas fait dans la
direction du rassemblement national même
si celui-ci veut ce qui est beaucoup
plus exigeant ou beaucoup plus dur
réserver les allocations familiales au
seuls citoyens français donc il y a
effectivement une une
ébauche de préférence nationale
c'est-à-dire de
traitement différenciés et assumés entre
les Français et le le et les immigrés
mais c'est pas là qu'à mon avis est la
plus grande victoire du rassemblement
national elle est dans le fait que euh
il y a eu un texte important sur
l'immigration et que ce parti a été
pleinement associé politiquement à son
vote c'està-dire que même si Emmanuel
Macron dit mais c'est vrai c'est pas la
loi du rassemblement national c'est vrai
que c'est plutôt la loi de Monsieur
rotillot pour pour faire cours elle
reprend l'essentiel des propositions du
Sénat il n'empêche que Marine Le Pen en
disant cette loi va dans le bon sens je
la vote et et par le fait que les voix
du rassemblement national se sont mêlé à
celles des républicains et à celles des
3/4 des députés de la majorité et bien
c'est un pas à mon avis essentiel euh
qui sera vraiment déterminant dans la
normalisation du rassemblement national
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que Marine Le
Pen a changé d'avis puisque vous savez
qu'au départ son parti ne voulait pas
voter cette loi c'est ce qu'avait dit le
président du parti Jordan Bardella c'est
une victoire en quelque sorte
métapolitique pour le rassemblement
national quelques symboles qui ont
été en tout cas quelques quelques tabous
qui ont été levés qui permettent à
l'avenir peut-être de de de de franchir
d'autres caps et de lever d'autres tabou
alors ça n'est pas certain parce que vu
le psychodrame que ça a été je suis pas
sûr qu'Emmanuel Macron se hasarde sitôt
à à remettre le le le chantier d'une
d'une nouvelle loi sur l'immigration
alors que la gauche a quand même
quelques quelques réserves de criis
encore absolument mais ça ça c'est c'est
c'est ça qu'on la reconnaît mais en
revanche je pense que le rassemblement
national oui pourra dire c'est aller
dans le bon sens et puis il y a à mon
avis une bombe à retardement on vient
d'en parler mais mais de façon incidente
c'est le passage devant le Conseil
constitutionnel si effectivement le
Conseil constitutionnel censure les
mesures les plus spectaculaires
c'est-à-dire les mesures de de de
préférence nationale au nom de l'égalité
entre les individus et bien Marine Le
Pen pourra dire vous voyez bien que il
faut changer de majorité qu'il faut
modifier la Constitution qu'il faut
véritablement une autre direction au
pays parce que sinon on ne pourra rien
changer c'est d'ailleurs aussi la
position des LR puisque vous savez que
dans leur proposition de loi sur ce
sujet il était prévu de modifier la
Constitution pour en quelque sorte
tordre le bras du conseil
constitutionnell et des différentes
juridictions administratives alors on y
vient c'est c'est c'est passionnant de
vous entendre sur ce sujet-là et sur les
autres bien évidemment cher Guillaume
mais sur cette question de du Conseil
constitutionnel parce que vous l'avez
étudié longtemps et de près si le
Conseil constitutionnel retoque un
certain nombre de mesures et en
particulier les mesures les plus
spectaculaires les mesures les plus
j'allais dire les plus droitières et
vraisemblablement d'après ce qu'on
comprend en tous les cas dans les dans
les échanges c'est un petit peu ce qui
est espéré en macronie ce soir euh
qu'est-ce qui se passe ah il ne se passe
rien le gouvernement est obligé d'en
tenir compte et donc de modifier en
conséquence sa loi donc ça c'est la
l'impact technique d'une censure du
Conseil constitutionnel et puis
politiquement Emmanuel Macron aura perdu
sur tous les tableaux je pense s'il y a
effectivement une censure
importante substantielle une une une de
de de d'un nombre substantiel d'articles
de la loi pourquoi bah parce que d'un
côté le le la la il y aura eu cette
déception politique de l'aile gauche de
la macronie et du côté de la droite il y
aura eu il y aura une déception sur
l'efficacité du texte
puisqueeffectivement si on lui enlève
euh ces articles les plus fort euh le le
le l'impact sera faible il j'allais dire
presque encore plus faible parce que la
vérité c'est que euh même si euh euh je
pense que cette loi va dans le bon sens
on découvre quasiment heure par heure
que sa portée pratique est extrêmement
faible moi je suis tombé de ma chaise ce
matin plutôt de mon lit parce qu'il
était assez tôt quand j'ai entendu
éisabet born sur France interre à qui on
disait mais ce sera combien le montant
de la caution demandé aux étudiants
étrangers pour être sûr
que ils repartent dans leur pays après
leurs études elle a répondu 10 ou 20 €
c'était ça l'ordre de € 12000 € en
Allemagne hein oui mais mais de qui se
moque-t-on c'est c'est pour ça que je je
je vais vous dire je crois que quand on
quand on est à la tête d'un pays
l'habilité n'est pas une qualité qu'il
faut qu'il faut plutôt que d'être un bon
manœuvrier il faut avoir une stratégie
et une vision la vérité c'est que sur ce
sujet de l'immigration Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas de vision en fait il est
profondément gêné par par par ce thème
parce que il y a
plusieurs plusieurs convictions qui se
qui se battent en lui la liberté de
circulation parce que c'est un libéral
l'émancipation qui fait que il faut
donner sa chance à tout le monde et en
même temps il voit bien que il y a un
communautarisme islamique qui se
développe dans notre pays de façon
extrêmement inquiétante et donc en fait
il essaie de temporiser et je je je
pense que c'est une séquence qui ne lui
sera pas favorable au final est-ce que
pour revenir au fond du texte si le
Conseil constitutionnel censure les
mesures les plus en tout cas les plus
droitières les plus dures concernant
cette cette loi c'est il censure
notamment donc ces 2 5 euh articles sur
les 88 que compte la loi
euh est-ce que le texte n'aura même pas
l'inverse de l'effet escompté qu'il au
lieu de mettre un coup d'arrêt comme le
revendique hein ce soir euh Emmanuel
Macron en tous les cas vis-à-vis de
l'immigration clandestine il a parlé que
de l'immigration clandestine en matière
de coup d'arrêt euh est-ce que ça n'aura
pas l'inverse de l'effet escompté est-ce
que ça n'ouvrira pas encore plus
pardonnez-moi l'expression mais est-ce
que ça n'ouvrira pas encore plus les van
alors
euh peut-être pas parce que euh même
s'il y a un petit tiers de la loi qui
est censurée ce qui serait énorme hein
ce sont c'est des proportions qu'on
qu'on qu'on voit très peu souvent dans
un projet de loi euh pour autant que ces
chiffres de 25 articles contestable
constitutionnellement sur 85 ou 88 soit
soit soit vrai je je il y a quand même
un message qui est envoyé qui est un
message de relative fermeté non je pense
que c'est plutôt politiquement que que
que que l'effet de cette loi sera du
coup affaibli voire contreproductif euh
vous avez je le cite he si vous n'avez
pas vu l'interview d'Emmanuel Macron sur
France 2 et on sur France 5 pardon et on
peut le comprendre parce que c'est ça a
duré longtemps vous avez la
substantifique moelle si je puis dire
dans le le live text du Figaro dont vous
voyez actuellement le le titre sur
l'écran et vous voyez d'ailleurs que
l'interview continue revient notamment
sur sur l'affaire de pardieu c'était
d'ailleurs assez piquant d'entendre
anneélisabeth Lemoine dire à Emmanuel
Macron que normalement c'était jusqu'à
21h mais ça pouvait durer plus tard
jusqu'à jusqu'à 22h et et que Emmanuel
Macron se tenait à la disposition des
journalistes il se tient à la
disposition des journalistes mais il y a
une il y a une chose sur laquelle
on on voit que le président ne se tient
pas en tout cas il se tient pas à la
disposition des Français sur cette
volonté qui est quand même très
clairement exprimé si je ne m'abuse dans
les dans l'opinion il y a un sondage
hlab qui est sorti ce soir qui montre
que 60 plus de 70% des Français
approuvent cette loi en l'état oui alors
même qu'il l'ont sûement pas lu mais ça
montre que ils veulent que on prenne des
mesures pour essayer de contenir un peu
l'immigration et d'un côté on entendait
Emmanuel Macron
dire il y a une volonté dans l'opinion
et d'un l'utre côté il y a quelque chose
qui refuse catégoriquement absolument
apparemment c'est le référendum oui il
refuse le référendum parce qu'il sait
que quelle que soit la question qu'il
pose cette ce référendum pourrait être
utilisé contre sa
personne au lieu de traiter le sujet qui
fait l'objet de de cette consultation
des Français donc effectivement mais moi
ce que je vois surtout c'est
l'opposition absolue d'Emmanuel Macron
et de son gouvernement de lutter contre
l'immigration légale il y a cette mesure
gadget d'un bilan tous les ans à
l'Assemblée mais on ne sait absolument
pas en quoi ça va consister et Emmanuel
Macron continue à dire que la France
n'est pas dépassée par l'immigration que
c'est plutôt quelque chose de positif il
y aura cette année une nouvelle fois un
demi million de personnes qui rentreront
légalement en France est-ce que ce flux
qui à mon avis une ville une
agglomération comme Bordeaux absolument
est-ce que est-ce que nous pouvons
continuer à à à à supporter ce choc
migratoire à mon avis non et c'est pour
ça que je pense que cette loia aussi
relativement peu d'impact c'est-à-dire
que elle n'est pas elle va dans le bon
sens mais elle n'est pas à la hauteur de
la de la du traumatisme et je pèse mes
mots que représente aujourd'hui
l'immigration incontrôlée pour pour une
très grande majorité des Français de
presque tous les pays vous savez il y a
un chiffre qui résume ça c'était un
sondage CSA de la semaine dernière 80 %
des Français pensent que on ne peut pas
accueillir de migrants supplémentaires
on va en accueillir 500000 cette année
Emmanuel Macron vous a-t-il convaincu
hein c'est la question qu'on vous posait
qu'on vous pose ce soir sur le site du
Figaro qu'on vous pose également sur
youtube il y a pas de réponse on peut
voter par oui ou par non mais en tout
cas on peut commenter on peut réagir
vous réagissez notamment sur le le
compte sur la page Youtube du Figaro euh
et cette cette Inter dire le pire c'est
que Emmanuel Macron croit à ce qu'il dit
euh et il a dit une chose également je
sais pas si ça a retenu votre attention
euh je tiens à vous rassurer je ne vais
pas m'arrêter là oui parce que euh c'est
c'est l'essence du macronisme les
macronisme ce n'est pas c'est pas une
doctrine c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs il y a un certain nombre de
sujets sur sur lesquels il flotent le le
le macronisme euh c'est une force qui va
c'est pas un hasard s'il a appelé son
son mouvement en marche et donc il y a
cette idée que ce qui compte c'est de de
sauter les ha les unes après les autres
quit à en inventer d'ailleurs quit à
créé des sujets qui n'existent pas par
exemple
mettre l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans la Constitution alors que
personne ne veut revenir
en veut revenir dessus il y a cette
espèce d'idée de de mouvement permanent
d'activisme alors qui a été la force
d'Emmanuel Macron parce que en 2017 il a
été élu sur une promesse de mouvement
c'est idée que la France pouvait euh
être changée être être réformée en
profondeur être modernisée je crois que
l'exercice qu'on est en train auquel on
est en train d'assister ce soir cette
cette opération de communication qui
n'en finit pas euh on va voir les
audiences mais je crois que il y a une
forme de lassitude des Français par
rapport à ça alors ça ça sera
intéressant parce que la précédente le
précédent passage d'Emmanuel Macron dans
cet avou le 18 avril 2022 de mémoire
avait été un record d'audience donc on
va on va justement regardera ça dans les
heures qui viennent pour voir si
Emmanuel Macron a défaut d'avoir
convaincu avant d'avoir convaincu en
tout cas a été a été
suivi juste sur la question de
l'immigration si je vous pose la
question Guillaume ça va s'en dire mais
ça va mieux en le disant c'est clair
vous il ne vous a absolument pas
convaincu alors il ne m'a pas convaincu
parce que quand il dit que ce texte je
le cite est une défaite pour le
rassemblement national je crois qu'on
est dans un délis de réalité rarement
atteint je veux bien que quand on est à
la tête de l'État on ne peut pas faire
des actes de contrition parce que sinon
on s'affaiblit mais je pense que le
Président de la République n'a rien à
gagner à à à nier ainsi une réalité qui
est que cette loi même si elle est très
largement insuffisante c'est un tournant
c'est un tournant répressif et que comme
disait méchamment François
Hollande je crois que c'était chez nos
confrères du monde cet après-midi
Emmanuel Macron n' n'a pas eu besoin des
votes du rassemblement national
puisqu'il a repris ses idées dans cette
loi et je crois que cette cette volonté
de dire à la fois que cette loi n'est
pas du rassemblement national mais
qu'elle ne lui plaît pas cette situation
cette position qu'il croit intelligente
et habile à mon avis elle l'affaibli
c'était l'une des premières fois si je
ne m'abuse où il défendait aussi
clairement aussi
explicitement et qu'il utilisait aussi
clairement et aussi explicitement
l'expression en même temps oui
absolument parce
que dans le passé il a considéré que
c'était parfois une caricature de son
action mais aujourd'hui c'est c'est
c'est relativement évident c'est pas un
en même temps dans la loi parce que la
loi encore une fois elle va clairement
vers la droite c'est un en même temps
dans son attitude c'est-à-dire qu'il dit
à la fois qu'il assume cette loi et et
et qu'elle le met mal à l'aise et qu'il
y a des choses je le cite encore qui ne
lui plaisent pas donc euh il se dit je
vais réussir à à en tirer le crédit tout
en me laissant à l'écart de de de ce qui
peut choquer c'est une position encore
une fois de d'habileté mais qui je pense
pas est de nature à à à imprimer dans
l'opinion c'est pour ça que je pense que
cette séquence au final sera négative
pour le chef de l'État euh Guillaume il
y a un autre point qu' a abordé Emmanuel
Macron dans cette interview euh je
voudrais y revenir rapidement c'est la
fin de vie
euh madame Macron donc a bien confirmé
qu'il y aurait un texte et qui prévoit
euh l'interruption euh en tout cas la
possibilité
euh d'interrompre la vie en cas de de
maladie de maladie incurable là cette
fois-ci il l' confirmeré sans employer
d'ailleurs le terme euthanasie sans
employer le terme suicide assisté bien
sûr bien sûr il a expliquer avec un ton
volontairement enrobant euh pour ne pas
dire dousereux que euh il fallait euh
accompagner la fin de la vie de façon
humaine à à aucun moment il ne veut
nommer les choses je pense que c'est un
sujet qu'il faudra suivre de très très
près parce que là encore il y a la
volonté de de de de de de faire changer
les choses sans le dire en tout cas ce
qui est certain pour ceux qui pensaient
que Emmanuel Macron pourrait reculer non
il ne reculera pas il l'a dit ce sera en
février il ne reculera pas ce sera en
février est-ce qu'il peut se produire
sur ces questions ont là euh des
blocages des débats des polémiques euh
des psychodrames peut-être comparables à
ce que l'on vient de connaître sur
l'immigration et bien je n'en suis pas
certain par je crois que il y a chez les
députés de droite en particulier une
volonté d'apparaître moderne une volonté
de syndrome gcard d'accompagner le le
fait que le choix individuel doit être
supérieur à tout que la société n'est
plus légitime pour imposer des règles de
vie et des règles de protection donc
j'espère me tromper mais je pense que il
y aura moins de mobilisation que sur
cette loi immigration on aura peut-être
des surprises à gauche parce que j'ai vu
que Baré George Buffet avait préfacé un
livre de soignants qui sont des
syndicalistes de gauche d'ailleurs de sa
saintel qui s'oppos à la dérive libérale
je cite que constitue la loi sur
l'ethanasie ça sera intéressant de
suivre un autre point et ce sera
peut-être le dernier Guillaume avant de
de vous de vous libérer mais vous me le
disiez hors antenne avant que on
commence ce live c'est une info que vous
allez voir d'ailleurs chers internautes
sur le player et qui se trouve sur le
live text c'est euh pour la première
fois euh l'existence la révélation de
l'existence de plan B ou de plan C pour
la cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
olympique qui doit avoir lieu en juillet
prochain on le sait les forces de
sécurité sont extrêmement réticents sur
le principe de cette cérémonie
l'ouverture qui doit se dérouler sur la
scène sur 6 km sauf que ça veut dire que
vous devez en sécuriser 12 parce que il
y a deux berges sur un fleuve ça vous a
pas échappé jusqu'à présent Emmanuel
Macron qui éta à l'origine de cette idée
ne voulait absolument pas accepter le
fait que ça puisse être non responsable
à l'Élysée on on m'a dit il y a 15 jours
qu'il n'y avait pas de plan B voilà que
Emmanuel Macron commence à rétropédaler
il est possible que ce soit le premier
pas d'une sorte de de de retour à à à
une cérémonie d'ouverture qui soit plus
sécurisée on nen est pas là mais
effectivement c'est un vrai tournant
merci beaucoup Guillaume je remercie
également Jean-Paul et Nathan qui nous
avaent rejoint sur le chat de Figaro et
vous tous qui nous avveent rejoint
également sur la page Youtube du du
Figaro merci beaucoup de nous avoir
suivi vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
les infos du sur euh cette intervention
du chef de l'État sur France
d'abord je pense en regardant France 5
he c'est je sais pas si c'est si c'est
fini ou pas vous pouvez faire faire les
les les prolongations en tous les cas
apparemment le président ne s'en lassait
pas et les dernières infos sur le live
text du Figaro qui se trouve ici puis
vous allez pouvoir suivre Guillaume
roquet ce soir en direct c'est chez nos
confrères de LCI absolument à 22h à
partir de 22h allez on vous laisse
partir parce qu'il faut traverser Paris
merci beaucoup Guillaume et merci de
nous avoir suivi chers internautes et on
se retrouve très vite sur le Figaro vous
voyez de toute façon l'info continue là
aussi allô
ouais je suis en train d'arriver
monsieur je suis là dans 35
secondes merci beaucoup salut camarade
salut merci beaucoup je t'en prie écoute
c'était pas pas transcendant mais je
sais pas mais en fait il il me fatigue
tellement il m'énerve tellement que
j'arrive à
l'écouter allez ciao ciao ciao
hop
là